a movie starring Nick Siri and Deadpool
I'm not going to be the first one to
address that I'm definitely not gonna be
the last one to address that a lot of
people are probably going to address
that why cuz the [ __ ] cool the hit
man's bodyguard so the hit man's
bodyguard is a movie starring Ryan
Reynolds and samuel l.jackson as Ryan
Reynolds and samuel l.jackson Ryan
Reynolds is a quick talking sarcastic
dick who's a bodyguards bit down on his
luck because someone died on his watch
at one point when he has to escort
samuel l.jackson who plays the cool
efficient samuel l.jackson ish hitman
who uses the word [ __ ] in about
every sentence he needs to escort him to
court so he can be a witness so big bed
evil Gary olden can be put away for very
long time so now we kind of have a weird
obscure buddy roadtrip ish movie
Ryan Reynolds stands out in the way Ryan
Reynolds does I'm not saying this is
groundbreaking for him because really
Ryan Reynolds is the same thing and a
lot of stuff but it's entertaining to
watch him go there there's a reason he
does it same with samuel l.jackson like
i already addressed these guys are not
breaking any ground with their roles but
they do work and half the time they work
well together the other half you're like
you two clearly you know each other's I
supposed to annoy each other but it
really kind of comes off the screen and
onto you and you're like are you guys
having fun but in that it is neat to see
a friendship grow as the movies going on
and what started out as kind of an odd
couple pairing so I enjoyed that also
there are a couple action sequences in
this movie that are undeniably
entertaining however the plot was a bit
messy all over the place and again wants
to be convoluted because a lot of movies
feel like convoluted means clever they
sound me doc that's close oh now it's
gone convoluted does not mean clever
convoluted simply means convoluted which
makes the movie unfocused if you want to
talk about in focus we'll talk about the
runtime the movie is two hours long it
could have been a half an hour shorter
it could have dropped its runtime by 25%
at a point you're likely to be a good
time for the movie to wrap up not
wrapping up yet when the movie finally
does wrap up you can clearly point out
you're like the movie could have done
without that could have done without
that could have shaved that off you can
definitely find a half an hour to cut
out of this movie and there was wasted
opportunity Gary Oldman I don't know why
he's in this movie other than to say
Gary Oldman's in the movement could have
been anybody whatsoever maybe they
wanted to throw back to the days of old
when Gary Oldman played a lot
bad guys in which case is this movie a
throwback and I don't think the movie
knows this movie really has a big case
of identity crisis what does it want to
be is it a spoof movie is it a throwback
to 80s action movies is it throwback to
90s action movies or is it a modern-day
Odd Couple action movie you look at one
of the posters for this movies almost
like they all sat around they were like
oh well we do have the guy who plays
dead pulling this move in so let's make
like a Deadpool ish poster I feel like
Deadpool would be in a poster that looks
like that because it's the hit man's
bodyguard it's proof in the body garden
fairy Deadpool but it just projects the
wrong image for the movie because this
movie is not a spoof it has comedic
moments in it but the movie doesn't
really commit to that angle right and
this one really bothered me there are a
lot of scenes in this movie where the
light is totally it's ghosting like when
someone's standing in front of a window
or a light or something the light is
bleeding over them washing them out
we're not talking on that stylistic lens
flare JJ Abrams kind of way that does
work was really sloppy and though I do
think it was a conscious choice to do it
it just was washed out in foggy as [ __ ]
I'm probably not going to remember this
one in t-minus a couple days if already
forgot alright guys so we're going to
August now summer is clearly winding
down but the hit man's bodyguard have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]